what is going on there reject Nation we
have made it here to the final episode
of Superman and Lois excited to enjoy
this last rodeo with y'all it's called
Waiting for Superman nice guys leave a
like that'd be super duper appreciated
and also uh full-length watch along is
where you sync up with the time code for
Superman Lois are available for a super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
over there we cover many shows where
some are at the same tier for exclusive
highlights and watch alongs included
also thank you to the prepper
because there's more than just boys now
who uh help us set it down these
highlights in times of infinite crises
all right guys let's get to it
today I can relate to you not only is
the merging of the planet's real it has
happened if Ali succeeds
each of us will be forced against our
will to merge with our other selves
turning us all into
we don't know what better
be home
be with your loved ones
thoughts and prayers
[Music]
She's Waiting for Superman hey it's Kush
he's still not answering Kush come on
let's go look for him mom wait we said
to everyone that the best way to protect
ourselves is to stay at home lock the
doors and be with the ones that you love
which is why we're gonna go look for
your father you love Dad what I thought
you hated him for cheating on you with a
woman at the bar first Jordan now you're
keeping this from me how do we get back
to our Earth
all your time is Superman you've never
experienced anything like this like
world's suddenly changing
nothing like this what matters is that
we're all together yes family that's
from our kitchen a lot of this stuff is
my tablet
I'm gonna try to connect with my dad
maybe being on this world will help
somehow did I just see David Ramsey's
name oh
everyone just merges with their other
selves until they become monsters like
Ally it'll be a whole world full of
parasites that's just it though when I
was stuck where my dad is right now I
was able to connect to a suit it's
probably just the tour it doesn't matter
it should work this is your fault Jordan
I didn't get to tell her how much I
loved her I know I'm not gonna get to
say that to my dad either
no
dad can you hear me Dad
John Henry's still alive bug time it's
hard to say my dad kept breaking up all
I could make out is that he needs my
Escape pod then we have to figure out a
way to get it to him well let's not get
ahead of ourselves hey now
surprised to be transported to this God
forsaken place as you all were but given
the worlds have gone to pot a new
brother are in no shape to do much about
it seems my return is necessary
oh no
we're back we're back on our Earth
where's Mom
oh [ __ ] boys
Dad it's on my way to the farm when this
guy's trying to flicker like a strong
light
my Jeep is vanished and I'm wherever the
hell this is Clark and the boys are
still in our world we have to get back
not quite sure how we're gonna do that
well we need to figure something out I
can't just abandon my family while the
entire world is ending you didn't
abandon anything they abandoned you
yeah well the problem is everyone in
this world seems to want Ali to succeed
Clark said that Chrissy helped Anderson
find a bizarre version of me that's a
start
she must not have looked back when we
did this is Matt just phasing Between
Worlds a Multiverse of Madness
the mom is here
weird Manifesto
I'll take that as a no
foreign
himself we need to figure out a way so
that's what I'm gonna do your dad
doesn't have powers and we both know
your shady uncle's not a big fan of my
dad besides you need to stay with your
family you're our family too oh
yes
all they care about is virtue signaling
we are your white family
things were at Britain doesn't
maybe you want to talk to Superman whoa
sweetheart be careful
uh I'm not fighting for the world Cal
I'm fighting for you you and your family
the only people on this planet that
truly matter to me we will kill the rest
brother yes we will Massacre them all
[Applause]
come on tall
nice good shot Boogie
terrible terrible
God damn it towel
[Music]
I hear him screaming dad Ali's gonna
kill him not if I help
your hotel and you get out of there you
understand go
Jordan we gotta get you a suit now
[Music]
laser her from above
freeze her
Jordan
you saved my life nephew I'm forever in
your debt could you guys do anything to
stop alley yeah
yeah no being can defeat whatever things
she's become well you're wrong two
minutes ago with very different mindset
must have two minutes there
your cells aren't absorbing the sun's
energy well then I have to jump start
them
fly me to the city yes
it worked for you because I was The
Eradicator and even then it took weeks
of me floating around outstretched
before the sun which is why you're
throwing me into it wow tell I've come
to trust you as a friend and a brother
and now I'm asking you to do the same
this is why I was sent here to be
Superman sure and sound like Mom that's
because she's the smartest person in our
family just wish there was something we
could do don't lose hope and look after
that weird lady back there yeah
one thing I need
[Music]
don't worry
it's gonna work
I know well
don't lose hope
remember they announced they picked us
up for season three
so seriously don't lose hope
how would you like to proceed first I
need you to sign into my Escape pod then
use the Pod to follow me into the mines
fly up into the portal
his face in between yes the space
between our destination
we find my dad
close up give me your hand it's real
like Nolan Snyder thing about this
episode yeah well we can't find him
anywhere so if it's okay we're gonna
find him I'm sorry Lana but from what
the news is saying he's probably on that
other world
yeah
oh no where's Bizarro Kyle I hate to ask
you this but you being married all
important thing is that you go be with
your families
unless something catches fire
these people don't look like they're on
board a bunch of whack-a-doodles
they're waiting to merge they think
she's won not yet she has let's go find
Chris
let's go punch all these people in the
face
feels like we just licked a toad and
woke up in Candyland the OD had this off
the books program using Buford toxin
it's a psychedelic these toads secrete
[Music]
oh my God you've just straight up
disappeared
I'm scared
ugh oh
this merging is a terrible idea
boy howdy
oh Kyle where's my family Lois I need to
find my family
being with you
it's meant everything
then I wouldn't change a thing if it
meant not being your dad
we need to hurry how much ice cream so
we could blow up the portals I didn't
get that part of the message I thought
the Pod was to bring you back no it was
to bring XK so we could
I'll go back he wouldn't be able to
return I'm so sorry no wow that's kind
of beautiful holy [ __ ] yeah
but I have to believe it well well
you're always wear the impulsive one
should this be our final farewell I uh
well I want you to know I love you too
wow wow wow
good luck brother
just lucky to have you
oh
oh [ __ ] I mean the fact that he could be
out there
if we don't act now billions of people
will die billions and dads
oh I can't let that happen honey
transfer all of our remaining energy
from my suit to the bottom
flying too
this is like a Neo blomcam film yeah
leaving Karma Lois cheating on Lana
destroying my family this is all that I
caused all this all I wanted to see him
just once more
oh Kyle no one ever deserves to be alone
to you
damn Lois you just stuck there just
watching the planets collide
now this is what it's like with words
collide
Florida
Sophie Sarah
[Music]
You better kiss him he's earned it too
he's earned the kiss God damn it he's
crossed universes for you
not here I were just with her on the
other world she's gonna return
the freaking Sun ground and that's what
he needed to do
I've been working for the dod for a long
time I've seen things you would not
believe glimpses of other worlds and the
leagues of superheroes they have on them
and even though we only have your father
on this planet thank God that we do
because he's the finest of any earth oh
[ __ ] they just hope yet okay I sure as
hell have it your mother hasn't and I
guarantee you neither has Superman who
so they just clearly established that
this is a different world that's how it
sounds yeah
ah God shrill
it's working yes it's working
hey don't talk save your ex
wow
it worked
huh
the real MVPs
[Music]
no no
I'm gonna bite your head off
go Superman come on
what are we gonna do
look I need you to close your eyes
dad you listen to me I need you to hear
this I have always been so proud to be
your daughter oh
it's always been my hero
I love you Dad
I always will
and I'm gonna miss you I'm gonna miss
you too Buck
he's really accepted death
oh they get him yeah
oh God damn Jesus
foreign
so goddamn cinematic yeah
holy [ __ ] Super Saiyan
man
holy crap
foreign
[Music]
now I'm gonna kick your ass on both
worlds nah he's still gonna save him
one for each of you
[Applause]
oh
wait he's doing oh [ __ ] no way wind it
back my dude
oh
my God that is epic that is a gorgeous
shot that was [ __ ] beautiful
[Music]
that was such a beautiful shot holy [ __ ]
[Music]
no your lawn is applauding
[Applause]
what a great book and oh
so join me on this miracle Monday as we
express our thanks to the man of
Tomorrow himself our world's hero super
super I favorite Smallville
and don't you forget it
Sarah go talk to Jordan congratulations
mayor on being exactly the kind of
leader you have always wanted this town
to have it means a lot coming from you I
wish I'd been there to vote for you to
help with the campaign to be there when
things were hard
you were busy that's no excuse if you
really cared she would have been kind of
rough dealing with Armageddon my first
week is Mayor so let's call it even
that's right that's right the world was
counting on you Lana
[Laughter]
[Music]
told me everything I just needed space I
guess a part of me thought that I could
protect my girls from all this craziness
which was naive but even if Sarah didn't
know it'd be tough getting through this
life without you in it same
from now on I will always be completely
honest about everything
together the man of Tomorrow something I
wanted to talk to you about first
it's about Clark
yeah okay well I did check him out and
it looks like Clark's really only worked
at the Daily Planet Chrissy no I know I
mean oh my god oh [ __ ] oh oh no Clark is
Superman there it is
your husband Clark Kent he's Superman
and you're not kidding wow I'm sorry I'm
kind of overwhelmed I know it's a lot I
need space
well then why tell me because you are my
partner and you are my friend and I am
tired of hiding the truth from you
you deserve better
this is the biggest secret anyone's ever
told
ah yes
I'm getting kind of emotional this is a
terrifying responsibility
oh my god do I need to swear like an
oath of secrecy or something just not
telling anybody else would be great so
yes
[Music]
and don't piss him off okay he's got a
terrible temper
in universe who owns the rights to
Superman hey Jack was his girlfriend you
see that hey looking back it makes so
much sense it's the biggest secret in
the world and you have to really trust
somebody I do trust you Sarah I know and
I never said sorry
for betraying that trust this summer at
Camp when I kissed Aubry thank you
I was like
we just kind of need to reset be honest
talk to each other and see how we feel
let's start from the beginning I won
those polls tell my brother and I that
was the first time I used my Powers I
didn't even know it yet remember when I
lasered that party you didn't know that
did you
tag I kind of use my powers on the
football field
at this time at that time
okay was you around always hmm
shall we
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay Kyle I know that you're trying and
I know that you want to fix things but
I'm not there oh God damn it um
that's pretty real how about our last
dance
oh poor guy
I just wish
I wish everybody could be as happy as I
am right now
you never stopped trying to help people
be
that is beautiful
[Music]
show had me going
or is that David Ramsey Camp God damn it
is it about to be incoming
said his name at the beginning why would
they say that I guess I wanted to know
if there was ever actually a moment when
you felt complete just after we started
to merge where I felt huge that's not
the same thing but if that's not what
you wanted why didn't you stop because
we couldn't survive that way we need
others we can't be well guess now you
won't have to be where's Lucy yeah
that's what we need the real wrap up on
can I help you yeah dude Jonathan and
Jordan Ted live here that's us
well these are for you are you serious
no no no no they're not um I'm sorry
there must be a misunderstanding does
that say who these are from just says
Uncle towel
oh my God maybe this is his way of
apologizing his very misguided and
irresponsible way towel yo guys as a
heads up display it's holographic look
at this
where do you think it went anyways
[Music]
oh hello weird Smallville
foreign
I understand that in any direction here
after all the trouble your wife caused
yes yes she she was an naughty one
wasn't she
tell me what's the name again
why would they ruin that oh my God he's
recruiting John henriers for Marcus
we want the solar flare to kill Superman
yes
glad that didn't work out yeah
me too you might have a seat
you know people are expecting you to the
head of intergang dude has his hand in
pretty much all the wrong pies what's
that got to do with me nothing but from
what I can tell on this planet Bruno
Manheim is the person that killed Joy ah
[Music]
that'll do it tell me when you get there
I just want to make sure you're okay
don't worry I'll get her there safe and
sound
this episode like an hour and 25 minutes
that's right part two airs in three
weeks
you guys have a good trip love you I
love you
bye Lucy bye guys we love you again it's
nice although when you said Ocean
Adventure I was imagining Cabanas or
drinks with teeny umbrellas or at least
we're going to Atlantis Jordan C6 no I'm
not let's just bring plan of yours
anyway you get seasick well I guess I
can get a one week or something yep only
this time it's for all of us what we can
all find some Solitude we're doing this
as a family and just so you know my mom
she's been wanting to meet you she's got
some pretty cool Kryptonian technology
you might be interested in the first
I'm gonna pump you full of XK
oh my God a brand new Fortress of
Solitude
I think the crystal might have expired
or something
oh
the beginning
how does it affect local sea life
how would Jonathan find it
we'll build a truck Bridge
I feel like that's easier to find than
one in the mountains yeah it doesn't
really blend in when it's just jutting
out of the ocean yeah
but hey what do we know right okay it's
okay they'll put some kind of Shield
that scrambles the visual over it SNL
all right yeah man
um yeah
all right cool well
here we are here we are guys we made it
um
we are at the end of a lovely lovely
season Arc
all right sweet sweet digs Well Chrissy
now knows that's my big takeaway here
that's right Christy knows the truth
Chrissy can spread the news far and wide
waiting two whole seasons for Chrissy to
find out every episode kept wondering
when's it gonna be and here we are we
finally got it very happy about that
that was funny
uh regardless of uh whatever some spots
in the beginning felt a little bit too
rushed but overall the man thought it
was a pretty great season finale I feel
like an actual
it suddenly made the whole season feel
like a part two of yeah of a Superman
and Lois story it's amazing like put it
in this different kind of context box of
season one is a part one movie and this
is the man of tomorrow
um sequel yeah that's just how it kind
of registered and I thought it was uh
pretty great and I I think that you know
even the
the whole merging sequence I thought was
beautifully captured it was so cinematic
and and fraught and just uh so chaotic
and I thought that they the way the
editing handled it with the you know the
flashy visuals where things were just
going in and out of opacity and just
emerging shifting in and out itself
yeah it was great it was cool it was
really really well handled and uh I
think that it was
tense and emotional and I think the the
way they handled the going back and
forth between all the different story
lines whether that be like they there's
a lot of wrapping up on on things during
the chaos and then afterwards but even
something that felt a little bit more
dream and space world like with John
Henry irons and Natalie being stranded
out there
was just so beautiful it was mesmerizing
and it felt like a different movie but
Blended in with what we were doing
and they're still epic so yeah I think
overall a pretty awesome season two
finale and
I had a great time had a great time good
season overall I don't know if I like it
one of the first season I don't care to
find out if I do right now but hey as it
stands I think it was a pretty great
season too yeah absolutely I I'm really
happy with the overall season and this
finale I feel like
yeah it's like there are a couple of
moments where I was like ah maybe just
like a little bit longer on the reunion
when Kyle finally gets back or something
or when John Henry and Nat finally get
back just for that catharsis but yeah
for the most part just looking back over
the season and the threads that they've
used and paid off and developed over
time and the way that they've allowed
all these character beats and things to
expand and contract in ways that feel
you know appropriately tangential to the
way life feels while also having all
this you know big world-rending Bizarro
stakes and everything like I I'm
constantly dazzled by what they managed
to do with this show because I love it
on so many levels and it fires on all
the cylinders I feel like the best you
know superhero fiction does and and yeah
like what they've built on top of season
one with like Taro and things like that
and seeing how that grows and pays off
and with John and Nat how that grows and
pays off further
um I don't know they just have like such
a great attention to the scope and scale
of their world and how to you know
really hone in on pertinent and very
compassionate and human feeling drama
but also yeah having these really cool
and engrossing you know sci-fi plots and
things like that like yeah I don't know
necessarily I wouldn't say Ali Alston is
as good a villain as an individual
character as say Torah was mortgage Edge
was in the first season but what she
represented and what she brought about I
thought was really engaging and really
enjoyable to watch and yeah like I don't
envy them having to edit this down but I
thought for the amount of compacting
they probably had to be conscientious of
they did a really really great job of
making the first half of this feel
really intense and really thrilling but
also communicating that sense of
Gravitas that just comes with knowing
that this is the final stand and then
paying off the second half with yeah
this relief and This Joy and this
emotional catharsis and and the things
they chose to make sure to tie up yeah I
just thought this was really graceful
and really wonderfully done and there's
not there are characters where in future
I'm like yeah I would like to see this
character maybe treated it's like any
character I
I've had like they're they're yeah
they're good at growing and building on
their characters like any gripes I would
have are things that I could absolutely
see improving upon you know another
season with you know a shifting focus
and things like that
um especially like with Chrissy I feel
like this new revelation could take her
in some interesting directions and
things
um but yeah as it stands I thought this
was terrific it's all about Chrissy man
all about her oh about Chrissy
and uh and hey maybe Lucille uh be cool
next season Aunt Lucy well either they
pay tribute to Christopher Reeves there
um
they they do that in this show
there quite a bit I never I didn't think
we'd be getting the whole spinning
around the world yeah zipping around the
globe and they've made it look so cool
like that's often memed
yeah I mean they may look cooler than
the first movie and I I think they were
some of the coolest Superman visuals
ever you know especially that whole like
suned up look that he had just being
infused with all of it and uh to me I
mean the what makes this show really
like I did enjoy the intensity of it
there's like that bit of that contagion
Vibe and some of that editing Direction
style of like a Snyder Nolan film where
with the with the handheld and The
Cutting around different storyline
events where you can still pay attention
but you're dealing a lot with like time
displacement and then shifting around
time there were some things that I
thought they could have done definitely
and then I look back on that like I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened to
like John evil Jonathan and uh I I don't
know what happened to trailed off it's
freaking this is evil Lana evil Lana but
then like Lois Lazaro Lois or not
Bizarro Lois but other world lowest gets
planted over here and nothing happens
yeah there to be like I'm watching stuff
happen so it doesn't amount to anything
and it's they they kind of treat the
moments like they would but they don't
uh it's not something I was thinking
about in the moment but you know I look
back on it it's like it's kind of weird
they just put that there when nothing
really happened this could easily be an
hour and a half and I applaud what they
squeezed 43 minutes into well I mean it
sounds like what they had to do is focus
on the emotion more than anything else
so so yeah and I I take that I'd have I
I take a few things not being
um touched on if that means getting the
emotional core down like with the
reunion of Sarah and Jordan Starting
Over Again would Natalie and I really
feel like Natalie and John Hunter irons
they come to this like great place of
understanding and I did like this John
Henry irons portrayal of feeling like
I'm ready to accept death and uh and and
you know the the whole thing with at the
boat at the end with starting a new
Fortress of Solitude together as a
family not something to keep separate
you know it's like learning to let
people in more and to trust more is a
big valuable lesson that everyone's had
to inherit and it did feel like a true
celebration in Smallville like there was
to go from like a chaotic mess to
something that feels like oh we're
appreciative of life is is a very warm
and tender feeling to leave this season
off with and I appreciate the nuanced
look to at Kyle and Lana because as much
as I'm rooting for because it's a
[ __ ] TV show yeah and like I'm like
nah nah I get it on real life yeah that
makes sense that makes a lot of sense
yeah I don't know I don't fault Lana
whatsoever I change your goddamn
feelings woman no no like I I even like
the line too of I believe that you know
um paraphrasing here but I believe that
you view me and the kids as everything
and that actually makes it worse that's
a really powerful line for to display
something that feels very real and close
to home for uh you know a cheating
father and and a faithful relationship
because you know that because of the
fact that his heart's in it and he would
still betray it does make it hurt more
so I I'd still liking it I think the
portrayal of the guy who plays Kyle is
great at they like they have flesh his
character out so much better this season
and I think Lana is more interesting in
the way they've wrapped that friendship
up there's so much they did here and one
episode that could have easily just been
a jumbled mess but it didn't you know
they played into the mess when it was
messy and like appropriately messy with
cool visuals and a good tone and then
they wrapped it up with a nice bow of
heart absolutely yeah it's a good way to
put that so yeah it's good good stuff
top-notch Telly Great Performances great
riding ruin David Ramsey's Cameo
on top I don't know why they did that
it's so [ __ ] stupid it's so dumb they
didn't even do that no you get people
freaking out if you didn't do that I was
watching it like we're distracting
people it came in the first season for
like uh one episode they put him in
there I'm like oh he's gonna be a real
character is it man I think the door
that it open I mean it seems like
they're leading into some type of
spin-off for John Henry irons to be in
either a season 3 plot
but from what they said about you know
what uh a general Lane said about how
there's other worlds of leagues of these
Heroes coming together
it sounds like that this is a very this
is a Zone separate Superman and and not
connected to like the crisis on infinite
Earths and or that stuff so I I think
that's a really because I felt like okay
is this still the same one that's
connected to the Supergirl that's maybe
a different Superman
apparently so and I prefer that because
then you get it to look like this yeah
then it can be its own thing and it can
soar to the heights it does without
having to be concerned with a bunch of
other plots yeah outside of itself yeah
so it does get me kind of curious in the
world building of what they're doing
with the Argus and the and the John
diggle of of this world because they did
he did establish that there's an Oliver
Queen in the last season that he was a
hero but it sounds like from the sounds
of things that there's there's one
superhero and that's Superman yeah and
uh now John Henry honors so and hey even
kids dressing up as John and Nat I was
happy to see that they're getting their
flowers I know I know the entire rounds
there like I think everyone just had a
great Arc and they managed to flush
everything out it all came together well
in the end and uh I did by the end of it
you know as much as I didn't really care
for the Ali Alston character when she's
like super being I did uh find that when
Superman got to her that is that John's
favorite work catharsis I did find that
catharsis uh of like yeah
kill him or blower you know freaking rip
her head off I water her like dead and
so I I did think they they landed that
that did that feeling of like yeah yeah
and I mean she looks super cool and her
eyes all glowed out and all the
lightning and so like they're good at
making the images very striking and all
I would have wanted was just more you
know scenes with meat on the bones for
that character but yeah when it counts
for the action you know and I like
turkota you know with the two of them in
the cell true I would watch more of that
character you know if they found on some
kind of not the same thing but some kind
of Taro way of re-contextualizing her
into the future so it's not just oh we
vanquished a villain and we never see
them again yeah you know but good stuff
overall really really top-notch Sarah
finally apologized thank Christ I know
the second she said that I could feel
like no [ __ ]
ways yes
yes this is so annoying
feels like that was six months ago when
that happened that's okay that's why
they spaced him out so much that they
probably were able to hear some of your
complaints and they were like hey we got
like a year to prep this finale so we'll
just address that we release these
episodes every six weeks so we got time
we got feedback yeah every week all
right guys well thank you so much for
joining us on the Superman and Lois
season 2 journey this was great this was
a lot of fun loved it loved it um
excellent excellent season
um got a lot to move on to for this week
a whole bunch coming up so gonna stay on
track here but thank you guys and last
but not least let's uh and this was
shout out to some patrons
differently sane you put on some
powerful muscle gains making those
muscles swell Levitt Odell Lauren
American Horse let's chart the course
for a god nose
hair is braided simply faded Joanna St
Louis
you are sexier than Marvel's Cree Rogue
Cree you are the sexiest of Marvel's
Creed
sj-94 opened the door to more in if
don't get me started on Justin Martin
there's just so many things to say about
him Rosie Beatty Darth
yoda066 you
Rosie Rosie Colin
Colin Phillip Jay Smith Jr
Jen Smith
Melanie LeBlanc
shank
patanka Josh Brolin Jason don't TJ
truckos
TJ hey bug he's a YouTuber thank you
guys so much for being part of our
patreon page you've made Todd a very
happy cat today look how happy he is
this is the face of Joy smile for the
camera baby guy okay if you're gonna win
this content petition you're gonna have
to smile and use some of that charm that
Daddy taught you okay
oh did you not put your makeup on don't
you Todd I told you not to smear that
makeup go out looking like this how
could your mother's gonna look like
you'd live in A Rat's Nest kill me Todd
oh Todd one job to do
sorry guys look we're we're gonna we're
gonna take Todd and we're gonna enroll
him in some classes all right this won't
happen again I promise we love you all
and hey pledge for Todd all right stay
pledged for Todd all right he needs he
needs makeup he needs coaching he's
gonna be a star one day
but uh you you there's real stars in our
eyes
love you Todd
foreign